We've covered a number of approaches for
cleaning up data within a field, but
after you've completed that step,
you can still have an issue
with duplicate records.
Duplicate records can end up in your
dataset because of a manual mistake,
where a record may have
been entered twice.
Or it could be some
kind of program error,
where some data was submitted twice.
Just as I've mentioned earlier about
getting a piece of mail with your name
spelled incorrectly, have you ever
received the same piece of mail twice?
That's a costly mistake, that should
never happen, since removing duplicates
from your data set or de-duping,
can be done quite easily.